OK, So what is the ultimate
state of peace wasn't actually
the final destination we all
imagine.
What if, you know, it was
actually, well, kind of boring?
Now, that might sound like a
wildly provocative question,
right?
Especially when we talk about
things like spiritual
enlightenment or Nirvana, these
concepts are almost always
painted as this ultimate,
blissful, unchanging end goal, a
seat of perfect contentment
that, well, we often spend our
lives striving for.
But today, we're going to dive
into a truly surprising
alternative perspective, one
that radically challenges this
deeply held idea.
And it invites us to maybe
rethink what true fulfillment
might actually look like.
It's true, isn't it?
That question feels almost.
Yeah, provocative is the right
word because for so many of us,
the whole pursuit of peace, you
know, freedom from suffering,
that is the ultimate answer.
It's the pinnacle of human
experience we're aiming for.
We dedicate ourselves to
practices, to philosophies.
We try to curate our
environments, to just eliminate
every last bit of discomfort.
We really believe that pure
serenity is the final supreme
goal.
We chase it.
We meditate for it.
We try to smooth out every
single wrinkle in the fabric of
our lives.
Yeah, we really.
Do But what if that very
pursuit, if you take it to its
absolute extreme?
What if it misses something
crucial, something dynamic about
what it truly means to live
fully, to actually grow and to
feel, you know, vibrant?
This deep dive today is really
designed to challenge that
deeply ingrained assumption and
maybe open a door to a more
nuanced, perhaps a more engaged
way of existing.
Absolutely, and to do that we
are pulling from some really
thought provoking material
today.
It's excerpts from Nirvana is
Peaceful and Boring While You
Still Need Suffering by Chris
Abraham.
Our mission with this deep dive
is really to unpack this
fascinating perspective on
suffering, on growth, and
crucially, on the absolutely
essential role of rest in a life
well lived.
We want to show you how
consciously embracing both
challenge and tranquility
together can lead to a more
fulfilling, more dynamic life, a
life that feels both rich and
purposeful.
We're trying to extract some
surprising Nuggets, maybe some
moments that might just shift
your perspective a little and
hopefully give you some
actionable insights for your own
journey.
Now the source material is
framed around a guru's teaching,
almost like getting direct
wisdom, but in a very modern
context, which I think really
sets the stage for a profound
and actually very practical
exploration.
It really does that framework.
It lets us step beyond just
abstract philosophy, doesn't it?
We get into something that feels
deeply personal and like
immediately applicable to daily
life.
We're not just sitting here
discussing theoretical ideals.
We're kind of stepping into a
conversation about the
practicalities of a balanced,
evolving existence.
It frames these huge concepts in
a way that feels less like some
distant spiritual goal and more
like a handbook for navigating
the messiness of being human,
right here, right now.
OK, so let's unpack the
surprising ideas straight away,
because it really does flip the
script on what so many of us
have been, I guess, conditioned
to believe.
The source starts by referencing
an earlier teaching from this
guru figure.
Apparently he'd explained that
suffering for most of us in
modern life often stems from
what he vividly and quite
bluntly called the shit.
Huh.
Yeah, not mincing words there.
Not at all.
Yeah.
And he meant those very basic,
fundamental, and frankly quite
uncomfortable things that,
ironically, modern life is
largely removed or made
incredibly easy for us to avoid.
Think about genuine physical
hunger.
Not just, oh, I fancy a snack,
but real gnawing hunger or
extreme cold, real exposure to
the elements or the intense
physical labor that was once
just required for survival.
Or, you know, the constant
threat of predators or conflict
that shaped much of human
history.
Things we barely even conceive
of now, most of.
Us exactly.
And his point was, if we simply
choose to see this, to really
acknowledge the immense comfort
and safety that is our default
setting in many parts of the
world today, the Nirvana, this
freedom from the kind of
suffering the Buddha was talking
about is actually readily
available.
It's right here, right now.
It's just a shift in perspective
away.
Right.
And this foundational idea, it
resonates so deeply with a lot
of contemporary thought, doesn't
it?
Things like mindfulness,
gratitude practices, even
certain branches of, say,
Stoicism.
It suggests that a huge chunk of
our perceived suffering isn't
actually caused by these
insurmountable external forces
anymore.
It's more about our internal
resistance to what is, or maybe
our attachment to what is and
our expectations.
It proposes that if we just
choose to acknowledge the
incredible comfort, the
convenience, the sheer abundance
of modern existence, then much
of the suffering we tend to
experience is in a way
self-imposed.
Or it's a product of our
internal narrative, right?
Our endless pursuit of what's
next instead of appreciating
what's right here.
That constant striving.
Exactly.
And society, with its relentless
drive for efficiency and
comfort, often reinforces this.
We're always striving to
eliminate all discomfort, even
tiny ones.
Think ergonomic shares, instant
gratification and entertainment
food delivery in minutes.
We've become so accustomed to
this highly cushioned existence,
and we often wait total comfort
with the ultimate good.
So this initial teaching from
the guru, in a way, it gives us
permission.
Permission to acknowledge the
profound peace that can exist
when those fundamental shits are
largely gone, when we aren't
constantly battling for basic
survival.
It's a powerful invitation,
really, to recognize the peace
that's already here if we just
look.
That makes so much sense,
especially when you think about
how much of our lives now are
just designed to avoid even
minor inconveniences.
Like you said, you don't have to
build your own shelter, hunt
your own food, or, you know,
worry about a Saber toothed
tiger lurking in your backyard.
So much of what used to be a
daily visceral struggle is just
gone for many of us.
And yet we still managed to find
ways to feel miserable, don't
we?
Which is fascinating in itself.
Oh, absolutely.
Human ingenuity finds a way even
for misery, right?
But then the guru sends this new
e-mail to the author, Chris
Abraham, and this is where the
teaching really deepens.
It adds this layer that for me
truly shifts the whole
perspective.
Because he added this crucial
bit.
Nirvana is peaceful, yes, but
Nirvana is also boring.
And that is precisely where the
paradox hits you, right between
the eyes.
It's so counterintuitive because
for so many people, the very
word Nirvana conjures up images
of ultimate bliss, doesn't it?
A state of perfect contentment.
It's seen as the final, supreme
goal of spiritual aspiration,
the end of the line.
So to hear it described as
boring, well, it feels almost
blasphemous, like a
contradiction in terms that can
really challenge deeply held
spiritual and philosophical
beliefs.
Totally.
It feels wrong somehow.
Yeah, we've been taught, or
we've absorbed the idea that we
should aspire to a state without
struggle, without want, without
friction, without desire.
So why would perfection, which
is often how Nirvana gets framed
in popular understanding, why
would it have such a strange,
almost undesirable catch?
This really challenges the whole
notion of what a perfect state
for a complex creature like a
human being might actually
entail.
It really reframes our
understanding, doesn't it?
It kind of bumps Nirvana down
from being the ultimate
destination.
It makes it more like a very
important stop along the
journey, a crucial resting
place.
And the guru score argument
clarifies this paradox.
Perfection, by its very nature,
has a catch.
Nirvana is described as calm,
soothing, pleasant.
All good things.
Definitely things we crave, but
crucially, the keyword is
unchanging.
There are no struggles there, no
challenges, no dramatic ups and
downs, no novelty.
It's a place of ultimate rest,
profound stillness.
Stillness.
Yeah, that's a good word for it.
And here's the kicker.
The analogy from the source just
drives this home.
It makes it incredibly
relatable, he says.
Like any resting place, if you
stay there too long, it stops
being fulfilling.
Yeah, you might love a vacation,
but you wouldn't want to live in
the same hotel room for the rest
of your life.
That image, a luxurious hotel
room, perfect for a week maybe,
but just soul crushing for a
lifetime.
It really makes you stop and
think.
Oh, that analogy is incredibly
powerful because it taps
straight into a universal human
experience, doesn't it?
And I would argue it taps into a
fundamental aspect of human
nature itself.
We are, I think, at our core
creatures that are wired for
novelty, for growth, for
progress.
We need change, so consider what
this implies.
Even when we achieve maximum
comfort, total tranquility,
complete freedom from suffering,
some innate part of us seems to
still seek change, new
experiences, or maybe a sense of
purpose that goes beyond just
existing comfortably.
Right, we get antsy.
Exactly.
Absolute stagnation.
Even if it's stagnation in a
state of perfect peace, it might
inherently be dissatisfying
precisely because we are
organisms wired for dynamism.
Our brains thrive on new stimuli
and challenges.
Our bodies adapt to new
stresses.
That's how they get stronger.
And our spirits, well, they seem
to seek evolution and expansion.
Meaning, if everything is always
perfectly calm, perfectly
settled, perfectly predictable,
what's left to strive for?
What's left to learn?
What's left to do that feels
meaningful?
Yeah, what's the point then?
Almost.
Right.
So the boring aspect of Nirvana
isn't necessarily a flaw in
Nirvana itself.
It's perhaps a profound
reflection of our own human
design, our fundamental need for
interaction with a changing
world.
I need to engage, to create, to
overcome.
It suggests that even in
paradise we might find ourselves
restless, maybe even, you know,
creating little problems just to
have something to do, something
to engage that innate drive.
Like making mountains out of
molehills just for the
stimulation could.
Be so yeah, that reframes
Nirvana.
Not as the end all be all, but
as like you said, a vital pit
stop.
A spiritual pit stop?
Yeah, I like that.
Which leads us directly into the
guru's next incredibly vital
assertion.
He says if you want to grow, you
cannot live in Nirvana all the
time.
Growth comes from stress.
Growth comes from challenges.
Growth comes from the friction
of living.
Now, this isn't about some, you
know, masochistic desire for
pain or glorifying suffering
itself.
It's a profound recognition of a
fundamental truth about
development, really in all its
forms.
Precisely.
That's a crucial distinction.
This isn't about chasing
suffering for its own sake.
That just leads to, well,
masochism or burnout, doesn't
it?
Instead, it's about
understanding suffering's
integral, maybe even
unavoidable, role in any form of
meaningful development.
It's about acknowledging that
true, lasting growth often
arises from situations that push
us, push us beyond our current
limits, situations that are
inherently uncomfortable,
difficult, or demand more from
us than we initially thought we
could give.
Right, the comfort zone thing.
Exactly.
Think about any skill you've
ever learned, seriously learned,
or any emotional resilience
you've gained, any real wisdom
you've acquired.
It rarely, if ever, comes from a
place of absolute ease or
undisturbed comfort, does it?
It comes from pushing through a
problem, grappling with a
complex idea, and during a tough
experience, or maybe venturing
into the unknown.
The friction of life, the
resistance we encounter, that's
often the very force that
sculpts us.
It makes us stronger, more
capable versions of ourselves.
And the source uses such a
vivid, really relatable analogy
to illustrate this.
The muscle, it says a muscle
only grows when you strain it,
when you stress it in just the
right way.
Too little stress and never
grows stronger.
Too much stress and it tears
apart.
It's so incredibly clear when
you think about it physically,
like weightlifting, but then
applying it more broadly.
I mean, what happens if you
never stress a muscle?
It atrophies.
It weakens.
Simple as that.
It's an undeniable physical law,
and this principle, as the guru
explicitly states, applies
directly to your mind, your
heart, and your entire life.
It's not just physical.
Just as a muscle needs that
precisely calibrated resistance
to strengthen your cognitive
abilities, your emotional
resilience, your personal
character, they all develop
through encountering and,
crucially, overcoming
difficulties.
If your mind is never challenged
with new ideas, complex problems
are genuinely different
perspectives, it just becomes
soft, maybe prone to rigid
thinking, complacent,
complacent.
Exactly.
And if your heart never
experiences loss or
disappointment, or the tough
complexities of deep empathetic
connection, it might lack depth,
real understanding, true
compassion.
So the delicate balance is
absolutely key here.
You need, as the source says,
enough suffering to push you, to
stretch you, to make you grow.
But, and this is critical, not
endless suffering that just
breaks you down, that
traumatizes you.
Right.
So it raises the big question,
maybe the $1,000,000 question
for anyone listening.
How do you know what's enough?
How do you find that line
between productive challenge,
that sweet spot for growth and
just destructive overload?
How do we calibrate that?
It truly is the $1,000,000
question, isn't it?
And there's no simple universal
formula, unfortunately.
It'd be nice if there were, but
the answer seems to lie in a
blend of, I think, deep
self-awareness and active
discernment.
Paying attention.
Firstly, it really involves
listening to your own signal.
Your body, your mind, your
emotions.
Things like persistent physical
exhaustion, emotional burnout,
that feeling of constant mental
fog.
Those are pretty clear
indicators you might be pushing
too hard heading towards the too
much stress zone.
The breaking point.
Exactly.
Conversely, feelings of
stagnation, maybe persistent
boredom or a nagging lack of
purpose that might suggest
you're in a too little stress
zone, Not enough friction.
Secondly, it's about
understanding the context of the
challenge.
Is this difficulty aligned with
your core values, your long term
goals?
Is it a challenge you've
consciously chosen for growth?
Or is it one that's just been
imposed on you with no clear
benefit or end insight?
That makes a huge difference.
Thirdly, it often involves a bit
of experimentation, taking
calculated risks, maybe stepping
just slightly outside your
comfort zone and then observing
the outcome, really paying
attention to how you feel
afterwards.
Do you feel stronger, more
capable, energized even?
Or did you feel depleted,
anxious, broken down?
Learning from experience.
Precisely.
And finally, it's recognizing
that this line, this sweet spot,
it's not static.
It shifts all the time based on
your current resources, your
energy levels, your support
systems, what else is going on
in your life.
So the mastery is in finding
some fixed perfect point and
staying there.
It's in continually calibrating
and adjusting your exposure to
challenge based on your internal
feedback and your external
circumstances.
It's about developing this inner
wisdom, this intuition that
guides how you engage with
life's friction.
And that discernment, that
ability to calibrate and adjust,
brings us right back to the
guru's crucial teaching on
choice.
This is so important.
He emphasizes that this isn't
about just passively enduring
suffering when it comes or
foolishly running towards it,
either.
It's about intentionality.
It's about agency.
He says mastery of life is
learning when to step into
suffering and when to step out
of it.
That completely shifts the
paradigm, doesn't it?
From being maybe a passive
victim of circumstance to being
an active conscious agent in
your own life's journey.
Kind of dictating your
experiences rather than just
reacting to them constantly.
This is where the practical
implications really, really
shine through.
It moves from just interesting
theory to actual actionable
wisdom you can use.
The guru states it so clearly,
so powerfully.
You choose Nirvana when you need
rest, period.
You choose suffering when you
want growth.
Again, a conscious choice.
And then this is key.
When the suffering starts to
break you instead of build you,
you choose Nirvana again.
See, this isn't a passive
acceptance of life's inevitable
ups and downs.
It's an active, conscious and
continuous decision making
process.
It offers you, the listener, a
really powerful framework for
navigating challenges with real
intention, rather than just
being tossed around by whatever
life throws at you.
Can you give some examples of
how that might look practically?
Sure, absolutely.
Imagine maybe you've been
working incredibly hard on a
demanding project at work,
really pushing your boundaries,
feeling the mental and emotional
strain building up instead of
just blindly pushing through
until you hit a wall, which so
many of us do.
You consciously decide, OK, I
need Nirvana now.
You actively choose to step
back.
Maybe you take a real day off,
No emails, no calls.
You engage in profound rest,
maybe a digital detox.
Whatever truly recharges you,
you allow your mind and body to
genuinely recover.
That's a conscious choice for
Nirvana.
OK, I get that.
Or consider the opposite.
You've been in a comfortable
routine for a while, maybe
feeling a bit stagnant, like
you're not quite reaching your
potential.
You identified A challenging new
skill you want to learn, or
perhaps a difficult but
necessary conversation you need
to have to move a relationship
forward.
You recognize this will involve
discomfort, maybe even fear or
frustration, but you choose to
step into that suffering, that
friction, because you want the
growth that's on the other side.
You see the value in it.
Choosing the challenge for the
reward.
Precisely.
And then maybe even during a
period of intense personal
difficulty, perhaps a family
crisis or a prolonged period of
unavoidable stress, you start
noticing those subtle signs, the
signs that the suffering is
beginning to break you rather
than build you.
You're losing sleep
consistently.
You're becoming irritable with
everyone.
You're feeling hopeless.
At that critical point, you
choose to step out, or at least
step back.
You seek professional help.
Maybe you prioritize radical
self-care.
You find ways to return to your
personal Nirvana, even if it's
just for brief, restorative
moments during the storm.
This kind of intelligent,
deliberate engagement with both
comfort and discomfort, well,
the source presents it as the
very essence of how to live
fully.
It implies this dynamic path,
not a static one, Is the way to
a rich and meaningful existence.
It really is a complete game
changer when you start to view
life through that lens.
It's so empowering.
It's not about finding the one
perfect static state and then
desperately clinging to it
forever.
It's about mastering the
transitions between these
states, getting good at the
dance.
And that brings us to another
great analogy from the source
that clarifies this rhythm, the
sports analogy.
The guru said athletes know that
rest is part of the workout.
That's so fundamental, isn't it?
You don't grow stronger just by
lifting weights every minute of
every day.
You grow stronger by lifting
weights than resting, than
lifting.
Again, it's absolutely
fundamental to physical
training, yet somehow we often
overlook it completely in other
aspects of our lives.
Yeah, it's such a perfect
analogy because it illustrates
those two essential, completely
inter connected components of
growth in basically any system.
First there's the effort, the
workout phase.
That's what breaks down the
muscle fibers, creates those
micro tears, pushes the system
just beyond its current
capacity.
That's the suffering part, the
stress, the challenge.
And then there's the equally
vital rest phase.
And rest isn't just passive
downtime.
It's the critical period when
the body actually rebuilds those
muscle fibers, making them
stronger, more resilient than
they were before.
Adaptation happens during rest.
The rebuilding phase.
Exactly.
Without the breakdown from the
stress, there's no signal for
the body to improve, to adapt,
nothing changes.
But without the rest, there's no
opportunity for the body to
actually do that crucial
rebuilding work.
You just keep breaking it down.
And the guru issues a really
clear warning against the
consequences of imbalance,
which, let's face it, we see
playing out constantly in modern
life.
He says without rest, you burn
out.
Without challenge, you never
improve.
It's that simple.
And it applies to everything
from physical training, sure,
but also to mental acuity,
emotional resilience, even
spiritual development.
It's a universal principle.
So he explicitly extends that
analogy to life itself.
It's not just about muscles or
athletic performance.
It's like a blueprint for living
well.
You rest in Nirvana, then you
challenge yourself in suffering,
then you return to Nirvana to
recover.
Sounds like a beautifully
orchestrated dance when you put
it like that, doesn't it?
A continuous movement rather
than trying to hold one fixed
pose forever.
It absolutely is.
The source calls it the Rhythm
Rest challenge.
Rest again is the dance of
growth.
I love that phrasing.
It's this continuous cyclical
process and it's essential for
sustained development and for
well-being.
You need both for the long haul.
And the guru points out a really
common pitfall, something that
plagues so many people in our
society today.
He says people get this wrong.
They tend to go to 1 extreme or
the other.
They either chase suffering
endlessly, never resting, or
they chase comfort endlessly,
never growing.
Sound familiar?
Oh yeah.
Definitely see both of those
patterns out there.
Right.
Both paths lead to an
incomplete, ultimately
unsustainable existence, just in
very different ways.
Think about the person who
constantly seeks suffering,
always pushing, always grinding,
maybe obsessed with productivity
or extreme challenges.
They will inevitably bird out
physically, mentally,
emotionally.
We see this everywhere in the
relentless hustle culture,
right?
Where chronic exhaustion is
sometimes worn like a badge of
honor.
They'll be perpetually depleted,
unable to actually integrate the
lessons learned during the
struggle or genuinely recover.
It leads to the state of chronic
depletion breakdown.
Yeah, running on empty
constantly.
Yeah, exactly.
And then, conversely, think
about the person who only chases
comfort, always avoiding any
form of discomfort, any real
challenge they might achieve.
A kind of superficial peace,
maybe, but that peace often
lacks richness, depth, and that
deep sense of accomplishment
that comes only from overcoming
meaningful challenges.
They miss out on the incredible
satisfaction of growth, of
expansion, of developing their
latent capabilities and
potential.
Think about the modern
convenience culture, sometimes
endless passive consumption,
streaming binges, social media
bubbles that just reinforce
existing beliefs without
challenge.
While these things offer
comfort, they can often lead to
a creeping sense of
unfulfillment, maybe apathy, and
definitely a diminished capacity
to adapt when genuine,
unavoidable challenges
eventually arise.
Because they will.
So you become brittle.
Brittle is a good word for it.
Yeah, these are the two
extremes, the two ways people
get it wrong.
And the guru suggests neither
truly leads to a full, vibrant,
resilient life.
And that's where the Secret
lies, isn't it?
The profound aha moment in all
this.
The secret is to use both.
It's not an either proposition
at all.
It's a dynamic interplay.
It's about integration.
And this circles us back, maybe
with even deeper meaning.
Now to why Nirvana can feel
boring.
It is restful, yes, profoundly
so.
We need that rest.
But it's also still it's
unchanging.
It doesn't have the novelty, the
friction, the excitement, or
that unpredictable texture of
life's ups and downs, the very
things that actually engage our
human curiosity and our drive
for meaning and purpose.
This highlights such a profound
aspect of the human experience
are inherent restlessness, even
when things are perfectly calm.
The source notes that some
people, even when they find
peace, feel restless because
there's no stimulation in
perfect calm.
That's a crucial insight.
I think it's why despite
meditation practices often
aiming for deep inner peace, so
many people, even those who
meditate, even those who find
spiritual peace, often step back
into the world.
They step back to work, to
create something new, to love
maybe to fight for something
they believe in.
They re engage.
They don't just stay on the
cushion forever, Yeah.
Exactly.
And this isn't a failure of
their spiritual practice.
It's not a sign they can't reach
deeper states of peace.
It's actually a testament to our
fundamental wiring as human
beings.
Deep down, maybe even
unconsciously, we recognize that
true growth and that feeling of
vibrant aliveness requires
friction.
It requires engagement.
So Nirvana isn't meant to be a
final, permanent destination,
not a passive retirement from
the challenges of life.
Instead, it's best understood,
as the source says, as a place
you go to recharge.
It's home base.
It's the safe place you return
to when the world gets too
heavy.
It's the sanctuary from which
you launch your next exploration
into the world.
And crucially, it's the place to
which you always, always have
the option to return to recover
and integrate.
So it's like that spiritual pit
stop, exactly like we said
before.
You go there, you refuel, you
check your tires, maybe adjust
your strategy based on what just
happened out there, and then you
get back on the racetrack of
life ready for the next lap.
But if you try to stay in the
pit stop forever in that perfect
quiet place, well, life loses
its texture.
It's a great phrase.
It becomes bland, muted, maybe
even Gray.
Peace without challenge becomes
dull.
So the whole point, then is not
to live only in Nirvana, to
desperately cling to it at all
costs, terrified of any
discomfort.
The point is to learn how to
move between Nirvana and
suffering with wisdom.
It's about knowing when to be
still and when to engage, when
to absorb and when to exert
effort.
It's about conscious navigation,
absolutely being the pilot of
your own experience, not just a
passenger being buffeted around.
And this brings us to another
really powerful image the guru
shared in the source material.
He said life is like a path you
have to walk one step at a time.
If you want to go somewhere, you
have to keep telling yourself
where you're going.
This speaks volumes about the
immense, and I think often
underestimated power of
intention and sustained focus in
sheeping our reality.
And he used this really
fascinating, almost whimsical
concept to explain it.
He talked about like talking to
the machine elves of reality,
describing those little helpers
that respond to what you focus
on, which is just such a unique
way to put it.
But strangely, it makes a lot of
sense when you think about how
our minds actually seem to work,
doesn't it?
It's a very imaginative, almost
mythical way to describe a very
real principle, I think, Whether
you call it machine elves or,
you know, the reticular
activating system in your brain,
or just the power of focused
intention.
Think about it practically.
When you decide you want to buy
a specific model of car, what
happens?
Suddenly you start seeing that
car everywhere on the road.
You notice details you never saw
before.
It happens every time.
Right.
Or when you commit to learning a
new skill, maybe playing the
guitar, suddenly opportunities
to practice, helpful resources,
other musicians, they just seem
to appear in your orbit with
uncanny frequency.
Now, this isn't magic,
obviously.
It's a profound psychological
phenomenon where you're focused
intention literally directs your
perception and consequently your
actions.
You notice what's relevant to
your goal.
So if you tell these L's or your
subconscious mind or maybe the
universe itself, through your
focused actions clearly and
consistently, OK, I want to go
to B, then C, then D, They or it
will help you perceive the path
and take those necessary steps.
But if your mind is scattered,
if your desires are unclear or
conflicting, if you're
constantly changing direction,
well, the elves get confused.
They end up taking you to random
places because you never gave
them a clear direction.
This really emphasizes how
crucial internal clarity is.
It translates directly into
external manifestation, or lack
thereof.
Without that clear inner
compass, you just drift.
You get pushed around by
external currents or fleeting
impulses, and that leads to a
life that feels kind of
accidental rather than
purposefully built.
And he also gives a warning
about that drifting, doesn't he
is if you wander off track.
If you lose that clarity of
direction, getting back can take
time.
It might involve going through
strange, uncomfortable stages
and visiting places you didn't
plan to visit on the way back.
It's not always just a simple
U-turn back to the path you
wanted.
No, it often isn't.
And this connects directly to
the practical reality of making
intentional choices and then
having to consciously realign
when you inevitably stray.
Because we all do Life happens.
It acknowledges that the path
isn't always smooth sailing,
even when you have the best
intentions.
Those strange, uncomfortable
stages he talks about, that
might be periods of intense
disorientation, maybe self doubt
kicks in, or even that
frustrating feeling that you're
actually moving backward before
you can start moving forward
again.
The messy middle.
The messy middle?
Exactly.
It's the friction involved in
changing course.
It's like the uncomfortable
sensation of a large ship
slowly, ponderously turning to
face a new heading.
Especially in choppy waters,
there's an inertia you have to
overcome, both internally and
externally.
But the guru's assurance woven
into this is that if you keep
telling yourself clearly where
you want to go, if you maintain
that intention, eventually,
through consistent effort and
renewed focus, you will find
yourself back on the desired
path, or maybe even on a better
path you discovered during the
detour.
This is why focus and intention
aren't just, you know, abstract
woo woo spiritual concepts.
They are immensely practical
tools for navigating reality and
actually manifesting the life
you truly desire.
But here's another one of those
deeply counterintuitive ideas
from the source that really
stuck with me.
He says steering can feel
boring, too.
Being in control can feel like
work, which is funny because we
usually think we want control.
But, he points out, we often
romanticize just letting go and
being surprised, right?
Even if that surprise means
ending up somewhere we genuinely
didn't want to be.
The guru makes this really keen
point that this resistance to
the boring work of steering is
often why people often resist
discipline and just feels dull.
Maybe in the moment to guide
yourself deliberately,
especially when compared to the
immediate thrill of impulsivity
or just going with the flow.
I think we've all been there,
haven't we?
That moment where I don't know
when Netflix binge feels
infinitely more appealing than
tackling that important but
slightly tedious task that would
actually move us towards a goal.
Oh, absolutely.
Daily struggle.
For many of us, it's a really
profound observation about human
nature and our often complicated
relationship with effort and
reward, especially immediate
versus delayed gratification.
The immediate hit of
impulsivity, or maybe the
thrilling uncertainty of the
unknown path can often feel more
alluring than the quiet, often
delayed satisfaction that comes
from disciplined, intentional
effort.
Guiding yourself, deliberately
keeping your focus on a long
term vision often involves
repetitive steps, steps that can
seem unexciting, even boring
day-to-day.
It lacks the dramatic highs and
lows that some people might
mistakenly equate with living
fully or finding exciting
surprises around every corner.
So yeah, people resist
discipline because it can feel
like a constraint, like a
suppression of immediate
desires, or just plain boring
compared to the short term
thrill of reacting
spontaneously.
And maybe there's a fear of
failure too, if you don't
actually try to steer.
You can't fail.
It's steering.
That's a really interesting
point.
Yeah, there could be a subtle
fear of failure baked in there,
too.
If you don't choose a
destination and try to navigate
towards it, you can't really be
blamed if you don't get there.
Plausible deniability to
yourself.
However, the guru stresses the
payoff of discipline of taking
the wheel is immense.
He says if you want to get where
you truly want to be, sometimes
you must take the wheel.
This is about true agency, real
empowerment.
It's about recognizing that
while spontaneity and going with
the flow certainly have their
place in a vibrant, enjoyable
life, true fulfillment,
especially in reaching desired,
meaningful long term outcomes,
often requires that boring but
absolutely essential, consistent
work of conscious, deliberate
steering.
It's ultimately the difference
between intentionally arriving
at a chosen destination versus
just, you know, ending up
somewhere by chance.
Or worse, ending up somewhere
you actively tried to avoid but
drifted into anyway.
OK, this brings us beautifully,
I think, to this synthesis of
the guru's entire teaching here.
It's like the culmination of all
these profound, sometimes
paradoxical threads.
It simplifies all of this
complexity down into a piece of
deeply actionable wisdom, he
says.
Don't treat Nirvana as your
final destination.
Treat it as your resting spot,
your home base, the quiet place
where you recover.
It's like Maven, he stresses,
not a cage you lock yourself
into.
Exactly.
It's your charging station.
And from that place of recovery,
from that safe home base, the
cycle continues.
Dynamically and purposefully.
He completes it.
From there, step back into the
world, into the challenges and
the suffering that help you
grow.
Choose the friction.
Then, when those challenges
start to wear you down, go home
again.
Choose rest.
This creates that fundamental
rhythm of life itself, a rhythm
that the guru describes using
another incredibly powerful
biological analogy.
It's like breathing, he says.
You inhale the piece of Nirvana.
You exhale the effort of growth.
Both are necessary.
Think about that.
You cannot perpetually inhale,
nor can you perpetually exhale
without disastrous consequences
to your health, your vitality,
your very life.
Similarly, you cannot
perpetually rest, nor can you
perpetually strive without
suffering deeply from that
imbalance.
Life is lived in that dynamic,
continuous exchange between the
two.
Wow.
The breathing analogy is
powerful because it really
emphasizes the dynamic,
continuous, absolutely necessary
nature of it all.
It's not optional.
It's not about choosing one
state over the other forever,
not about trying to live a life
of either pure comfort or
constant struggle, but about
integrating both, finding the
flow between them.
And the guru really stresses
again that this is fundamentally
a choice.
He says, quite pointedly.
Many people don't choose.
They just react.
Ouch, but true.
They either cling to comfort or
chase suffering blindly.
They just let life happen to
them rather than actively,
consciously shaping their
engagement with it.
And this right here is precisely
where the transformative
potential for you, the listener,
truly lies.
It's that crucial distinction,
the distinction between being a
passive passenger just reacting
to the bumps in the road, and
becoming the conscious,
intentional driver of your own
life's vehicle.
You can choose when to rest.
You can choose when to work,
when to engage with challenge.
You can choose when to face pain
constructively and when to
consciously let it go or seek
refuge.
This proactive engagement, this
conscious dance between the two
states allies for remarkable
balance, resilience, and
ultimately, deeper fulfillment,
as the guru profoundly
summarizes it, articulating the
ultimate mastery, the goal of
this whole approach.
You can choose to grow without
breaking and to rest without
rotting.
This, he declares right at the
end, is the secret and lesson.
It's the core take away.
It's about building genuine
strength, wisdom, and resilience
over time, rather than just
bouncing between enduring
hardship and escaping into
comfort.
It's not about trying to avoid
life's difficulties, which is
impossible anyway, but about
navigating them skillfully, with
an understanding that they are
often essential for your
expansion.
Preventing the breaking that
comes from perpetual unmanaged
stress, and also preventing the
rotting, that stagnation, that
lack of vitality that comes from
perpetual, unchallenged comfort.
Grow without breaking and rest
without rotting.
That really is the ultimate
balance, isn't it?
Such profound wisdom condense
into a few words.
So life isn't about finding that
static, perfect state of Nirvana
and the desperately clinging to
it, forever trying to build
walls against any discomfort.
Instead, as the source puts it,
life is about knowing when to go
there and when to leave.
It's about flow, not fixation.
It's about skillful movement
between these essential states.
Peace gives if you rest.
Suffering gives you strength.
Together they make you whole.
A truly integrated, vibrant, and
fully lived existence requires
both.
And that core idea of wholeness,
I think that's the truly
profound take away here.
Instead of seeing peace and
suffering as these opposing
forces, one inherently good, the
other inherently bad, something
to be eliminated, this teaching
encourages us to see them as
complementary, like two sides of
the same essential coin, maybe
like yin and Yang, each utterly
necessary for a rich,
meaningful, well lived life.
So as you reflect on this deep
dive today, maybe consider this
for yourself.
Instead of just defaulting to
either endless comfort seeking
or maybe endless reactive
struggle.
How might you start to
intentionally map out your own
life?
Think about the moments you
consciously need growth, which
implies choosing some friction
versus the moments you genuinely
need profound rest that Nirvana
state.
What might your own personal
Nirvana cycle look like?
What's the unique rhythm of
challenge and tranquility that
would truly serve your
development right now in your
life circumstances?
And maybe ask yourself yourself,
what's one small, deliberate
step you could take this week?
Perhaps consciously leaning into
a minor discomfort for the sake
of growth, Or conversely,
intentionally carving out a
moment of true restorative
Nirvana, time protecting it
fiercely.
Just one small step to start
honoring both sides of that
essential rhythm in your own
life.
Those are powerful questions to
ponder for sure.
A lot to think about there.
Thank you for joining us on this
deep dive into what it truly
means to live a fulfilling life
by embracing both peace and
challenge, and by consciously
mastering the dance between
them.
Keep exploring, keep reflecting,
and keep choosing your path with
wisdom.